la previsión para los próximos días es
de más lluvias lo que preocupa las
autoridades es un fenómeno en general en
todo Brasil hace poco aquí en Río de
Janeiro también hubo lluvias fuertes que
causaron inundaciones y muertos así como
en el sur del país la confederación
nacional de municipios Calcula que el
año pasado al menos
457 personas fallecieron por causa de
las lluvias y de los deslizamientos es
un dato preocupante porque las lluvias
son cada vez más concentradas en poco
tiempo cae mucha agua como aconteció
hace un año en petrópolis en tres horas
cayó la lluvia que se esperaba para un
mes entero matando a 235 personas hace
poco estuvimos allí para grabar un
reportaje y pudimos ver que un año
después siguen los destrozos con lo cual
la situación es crítica y la
preocupación con la lluvia crec